it's july 7th
2021 in the center of amsterdam and one
of the most famous dutch crime
journalists
peter herrers is leaving rtl boulevard a
tv studio
on longer lights strat it's around 7 30
pm
it's a public area in broad daylight
when peter
devries is starting to walk towards his
car it is parked further up the road
after reaching the parking garage where
his car is located
someone approaches him
peter herr devries is shot and hit in
the head
after fighting for multiple days in the
hospital peter herrers
passes away on the 15th of july at 64
years old
the motive still needs to be discovered
but a 21 year old man delano g
is expected to be the shooter and a 35
year old man
camille e is expected to be the getaway
driver
the shooter has been linked with the
notorious gang leader kirigantaki
who is currently on trial for suspected
involvement with multiple murders
drug trafficking and leading an
organized crime syndicate
prior to his death pedia herreras was an
advisor to nabil b
and the bill b was a former gang member
in taki's organized crime syndicate
who left out of fear and is currently
testifying against taki
before devries nabil b's lawyer derek
versus
was also shot and killed near his home
in amsterdam
if a link is properly established
between pedro davis's connection with
nabil b
and his death the list of fatalities
linked to tuffy's gang will grow
and civilians being shot in residential
neighborhoods in broad daylight
reflects a fundamental problem with
organized crime in europe
in the eu there has been a rise in the
amount of violence associated with
organized crime
and there is an increased willingness
for criminal groups to resort to lethal
violence
in 2018 amsterdam's police chief claimed
that his force was spending 60 to 70
percent of its time
attempting to compact gang-related hit
jobs and that young men would carry out
contract killings
for as little as 3 000 euros in 2020
police officers discovered in the
netherlands alongside 24 kilos of
ecstasy
baklavas and various torture devices
shipping containers
rigged as prison cells and torture
chambers
in spain the number of gangs dedicated
to drug trafficking has multiplied
in sweden with one of the highest levels
of fatal shootings already
that has been increasing 8 out of 10
shootings were linked to organized crime
and in belgium there have been increases
in violence attributed to gun battles
and grenade attacks
linked with trafficking through unfair
cocaine is europe's second most consumed
narcotic and the market for the drug has
been increasing
they are currently unprecedented
quantities of cocaine being trafficked
to the eu
in fact europe is often regarded as
having more potential for growth
and higher profits in the cocaine market
challenging the market in the u.s
in europe the prices of cocaine are
higher and the risks of interdiction
extradition and seizure of assets
significantly lower
and the current trade in cocaine has
also increased levels of violence
organized crime has also been increasing
their abilities related to the
production
and distribution of synthetic drugs
amphetamine methamphetamine and mdma are
all three produced in europe
and different to other drugs europe has
emerged not only as a global consumer
but as a global supplier in 2021
the european commission presented the eu
strategy to tackle organized crime
it's a five-year plan and the commission
will expand funding for impact
the european multidisciplinary platform
against criminal threats
and upgrade the problem framework which
allows different european law
enforcement agencies
to coordinate data on crime across
borders the commission will also propose
revising rules on confiscating criminal
profits
and modernize law enforcement to
effectively tackle the digitization of
organized crime
in the 21st century as a larger
coordinated solution
these policies according to us are a
step in the right direction
however we cannot say whether certain
policies being enacted earlier
or more powerful policies being produced
would have stopped the death of peter
arrives
but it should be abundantly clear that
policies that can do more
are a necessity when the status quo
hasn't done enough
you